dérangère bourguignons en charge de la
dépendance visité hier la marpa écoles
des deux aires de souvigny de touraine
un établissement où les personnes âgées
sont en contact régulier avec les élèves
de l'école toute proche
un modèle à généraliser selon la
ministre ne cache pas les résidents de
la marpa écoles semblent enchantés
régulièrement en lien avec des enfants
du primaire et de la crèche
tous y trouvent une ambiance conviviale
voire une seconde jeunesse
ça nous redonne goût est la ville de
voir un enfant pour moi c'est
merveilleux c'est l'avenir bons copains
on se parle on se raconte un peu nos
vies et c'est ce qui fait qu'on se sort
beaucoup moins sol chez nous un petit
peu en catastrophe parce que je chantais
de l'hôpital et je savais pas où aller
et depuis je suis très bien je ne
regrette absolument rien au contraire un
souvenez de touraine
ils sont 24 résidents comme eux qui
profitent d'un établissement
intergénérationnel où l'on donne tout
son temps aux personnes âgées en fait
beaucoup plus attention aux résidents
bien que je ne dis pas que en ehpad en
fait pas tout nécessaire mais on prend
beaucoup plus le temps la crise
sanitaire a mis en pause bon nombre
d'activités de la marpa
pourtant la ministre de l'autonomie
brigitte bourguignon là sur ce modèle
peut fonctionner malgré lakovic 19
c'est viable dans la mesure où on fait
les gestes barrière oui à la protection
la plus élémentaire
je crois que personne n'a envie de
mettre en péril qui que ce soit et moi
je travaille beaucoup sur le fait que
même dans d'autres établissements ou
parfois tous ces fermes et soudainement
et bien on continue de protéger certes
non n'isole pas brigitte bourguignon
entente inciter à la création d'autres
établissements semblables qui encourage
l'autonomie des personnes âgées